Sean Connery was once pulled over and fined
by a British police for speeding.
The officer's name was Sergeant James Bond.
The entire Super Mario Brothers game was only
40 kilobytes.
The average console game today is over one
million times that size.
Contrary to popular belief, the pyramids were
not built by slaves, but by well-fed, skilled
labourers, who were given proper housing.
In the 2004 Harvard vs Yale American Football
game, Yale students tricked thousands of Harvard
fans into holding up cards that together spelt
out “WE SUCK”.
Google is working on a fully modular smartphone
which replaceable parts, so you can upgrade
and repair individual parts without ever having
to buy a new phone again.
40% of humanity lives in countries where it's
illegal to be homosexual.
Nearly 3% of the ice in Antarctic glaciers
is penguin urine.
The brain of the colossal squid is doughnut
shaped and its oesophagus runs through it,
therefore, if it eats something too big it
could get brain damage.
Whilst British MPs are speaking in Parliament,
they are exempt from defamation laws, this
allows them to insult each other in any way
they choose without legal consequence.
When howling together, no two wolves will
howl on the same note, instead, they harmonise
to create the illusion that there are more
of them than there actually are.
More salt is used around the world for de-icing
roads than for human consumption.
During a car crash, 40% of drivers never even
hit the brakes.
The first ever shopping mall was in ancient
Rome, built in 100 AD, it was named Trajan's
Market.
It was four stories tall with 150 shops and
offices.
At room temperature, the average air molecule
travels at the speed of a bullet from a rifle.
Every day between 10 and 20 volcanoes are
erupting somewhere on Earth.
If you counted for 24 hours a day, it would
take over 31,000 years to reach one trillion.